bonjour à tous
merci de m'avoir invité
le temps est l'art parfait je vais vous
aujourd'hui vous parlez donc le thème
c'est en un clin d'oeil et c'est la
vitesse la vitesse c'est ma compagne
depuis toute ma vie professionnelle
puisque j'ai côtoyé des athlètes de haut
niveau toute ma carrière et leur but
essentiel
c'était d'aller toujours plus vite mais
en même temps je vois que vous adapté
très vite à ce thème puisque 18 minutes
pour parler de pourparlers d'un problème
aussi complexe
c'est déjà de la vitesse mais en même
temps je vais pas essayer de me
précipiter
c'est à dire que cette exigence la de
s'exprimer dans un temps donné
ça mérite d'y avoir réfléchi d'avoir
construit son intervention est d'essayer
de vous convaincre un certain nombre de
choses
la première chose c'est que le sport de
tout temps depuis l'antiquité à poser la
question de la vitesse situs altius
fortius c'est la devise olympique et si
tu sais la vitesse donc de tout temps
les êtres humains ont toujours eu cette
ambition d'aller plus vite
de plus en plus vite et quelquefois
d'aller plus vite que les autres
vous voyez bien que c'est pas la même
chose d'aller vite et d'aller plus vite
que les autres et à force de vouloir
aller toujours plus vite que les autres
on arrive quelquefois aujourd'hui
l'actualité nous parle d'un cycliste par
exemple à utiliser des moyens qui ne
sont pas toujours ce qu'on attendrait de
cette volonté de se dépasser soi-même
d'innover pour créer les conditions
d'aller plus vite
alors mon expérience d'accompagnateur de
tous ses champions et ses championnes
m'a appris un certain nombre de choses
intéressantes
la première c'est que tout ce qu'on vous
dit sur le sport
tout ce que vous lisez sur le sport tout
ce qu'on vous raconte à la télévision
sur le sport ne repose sur absolument
rien de réfléchi d'analyser sérieusement
et on vous fait passer des messages d
a priori des idées toutes faites que je
vais essayer de développer ici pour
quelques-unes
la première par exemple il faut être de
plus en plus jeunes pour participer aux
jeux olympiques
il faut s'y prendre très tôt faut
s'entraîner très dur etc
savez vous que la moyenne d'âge des
filles aux jeux olympiques ses 25 ans et
les garçons ses 27 ans conclusion
première idée atteindre le très haut
niveau dans une dans une activité
physique et sportive
ça réclame du temps ça réclame du temps
ça réclame de l'organisation du désir de
la volonté et on ne peut pas réduire ce
travail ce chemin là à quelques idées
toutes faites sur le fait qu' il était
doué mais j'y reviendrai un petit peu
après la deuxième
la deuxième chose importante c'est on
vous dit il faut commencer tôt précocité
c'est faux ce qui caractérise les
athlètes de haut niveau ça n'est pas le
début où il commence n'est pas comment
ils rencontrent l'activité c'est cette
espèce de big bang bizarre qui fait que
quelqu'un quelques unes à un moment
donné rencontre une activité et qui va
il va en enfer où elle va en faire sa
vie rechercher autour de cette activité
à devenir toujours meilleur en tout cas
meilleur humain c'est ça qui m'intéresse
c'est à dire que j'ai rencontré des les
athlètes de haut niveau qui ont fait
cette rencontre
ekissi s'est engagé avec un désire
absolument incroyable qui est
difficilement explicable et la
psychanalyse ou la psychologie ne résout
pas le problème
pour comprendre pourquoi jour après jour
mois après mois année après année
cette recherche un peu utopique de
devenir le meilleur du monde fini par
organiser une vie est fini par
concrétiser une vie le troisième aspect
c'est que je voulais souligner avec vous
à c les champions sont des êtres forts
j'ai rencontré que des êtres fragiles
j'ai rencontré que des êtres qui avait
transféré cette fragilité dans le désir
d'exister et c'est ce désir là qui les a
fait devenir champion mais à chaque fois
dans de nombreuses conditions
j'ai pu remarquer à quel point leur
fragilité et est finalement leur force
quand on n'est pas fragile ça veut dire
quand on n'est pas capable d'accepter
que finalement nous nous sommes
faillibles et bien finalement à force de
se construire comme quelqu'un que nous
ne sommes pas nous n'atteignons jamais
le maximum du potentiel que nous avons
en nous il faut accepter de se
fragiliser pour être très fort alors
évidemment c'est parce qu'on vous
raconte
mais en tout cas c'est ce que j'ai vécu
j'ai vécu de manière vraiment très forte
cette fragilité des athlètes de haut
niveau et surtout en condition en
conditions de compétition et du coup ça
remet en cause un certain nombre d'idées
a priori encore là quand vous serez la
longueur de temps et je voudrais juste
évoqué avec vous quelques temps
la première c'est le talent vous
entendez tous que finalement lui elle
est née avec une petite cuillère en
argent dans la bouche
ils étaient génétiquement programmés et
il est devenu champion voilà donc ça
c'est le talent on est talentueux et
donc il suffit juste d'arroser la plante
dans de bonnes conditions pour que
finalement ce talent préexistants
devienne une réalité dans l'expression
même de la performance
je ne partage pas du tout cet avis les
gens que j'ai rencontrés ces athlètes
que j'ai rencontré n'avaient pas à
priori ce talent qu'on désigne comme
étant la clé de tout il nous en sommes
avec un certain nombre de d'amis qui
réfléchissons sur ce qu'est la
performance et ce qu'est la complète
la performance en tant que condition
humaine c'est que ce talent là c'est
d'abord la capacité à s'exprimer à
donner du sens en situation de
compétition ça veut dire que et vous
allez voir à quel point dans ce cadre là
quand vous êtes manager d'une équipe
l'idée de vitesse est quelque chose sur
lequel vous avez intérêt à réfléchir
et donc cette capacité à trouver du sens
à donner du sens dans la situation dans
lesquels vous êtes c'est à dire être
dans sa capacité à l'analyse et analyser
les adversaires à construire sur vos sur
votre expérience sur ce que vous avez
vécu cette capacité donc à être en
situation de prendre les bonnes
décisions rapidement mais rapidement ça
veut pas dire n'importe comment ni vite
sous prétexte qu'il faudra aller vite
tout ça se fait rapidement parce que on
a construit un tel background expérience
que dans l'instant où l'on est on va
être capable de d'inventer la situation
et la décision qui semble utile à régler
le problème qui est devant nous et quand
vous regardez la performance de ce point
de vue vous voyez à quel point il est
important comme manager des équipes de
renvoyer à vos joueurs à vous à vos
athlètes
cette capacité de prendre des décisions
et donc comment ça se construit cette
capacité à prendre des décisions et bien
de manière assez simple entre guillemets
c'est à dire d'avoir en tête toujours
cette idée forte que quand on tente
quelque chose il ya une forte
probabilité qu'on échoue ce qui replace
l'idée des chèques complètement
différemment que ben je t'avais dit
comment faire
tu ne l'a pas fait donc tu as échoué
combien de fois entendons entendons-nous
cette formule très simpliste en disant
je savais que ce qu'il fallait faire je
suis ton coach pourquoi tu ne l'as pas
fait tu ne l'as pas fait ben voila tu as
échoué
ça détruit des mozart toutes les cinq
minutes cette vision ça veut dire que
des jeunes gens et les jeunes filles qui
ont en eu ce désir d'expérimenter parce
qu'ils sont riches de cette volonté de
créer des choses on va leur expliquer
que c'est pas comme ça que les choses
doivent se passer plutôt que de les
accompagner parce qu on a la culture
nous de l'activité et de vouloir les
accompagner dans ce chemin
donc voyez que et là on peut faire la
transition assez rapidement avec le mode
de management c'est-à-dire que quand
vous êtes manager de jeunes gens d'une
équipe nationale vous avez intérêts vous
à être énormément cultiver de l'activité
dans laquelle vous êtes c'est à dire
d'en connaître l'histoire d'en connaître
les fondements d'en connaître les règles
etc et ne pas vous précipiter et jamais
vous précipitez donc vitesse c'est pas
de la précipitation vite c'est pas du
tout cette capacité de 2,2 vouloir
prendre des décisions c'est à voir ce
recul nécessaire pour dans l'instant
savoir où vous allez intervenir ou pas
pour créer les conditions que celui ou
celle qui est l'acteur ou l'actrice de
ce qu'elle doit faire soit en
responsabilités et fasse les choix
disponibles immédiatement
au moment où il le faut il ya des
exemples très très fort je vais vous
donner un exemple concret chambre
d'appel d'une compétition de natation au
niveau mondial une finale approche
j'étais souvent à côté de la chambre
d'appel
un athlète me regarde je le regarde il
est livide il est blanc et je le regarde
et je lui dis mais qu'est ce qui se
passe
il me dit j'ai peur et je lui dis à ce
moment là mais la peur tout le monde a
peur
regarde ce qui se passe autour de toi
tout le monde est dans la même situation
que la tienne au moment où les choses
vont se passer
donc tu n'es pas en situation de
faiblesse parce que tu as peur il suffit
juste de contrôler ce moment et de pas
démontré à tes adversaires que
effectivement tu es en train de
s'écrouler dans la chambre d'appel et
que tu es plus un adversaire
mais la peur est une compagne permanente
des décisions et nous devons prendre
pour être les meilleurs et si on la
repousse sans arrêt si on n'accepte pas
on est dans un monde qui est pas un
monde humain c'est à dire on n'est pas
dans un monde où c'est autour de cette
capacité de prendre des décisions qu'on
va pouvoir aller le plus loin possible
donc voilà je voulais insister là dessus
après je vais vous donner quelques
exemples concrets sur la relation entre
la vitesse qui est finalement toujours
cette capacité à vouloir les plus vite
on l'a dit s'il tue ce total situs tout
à l'heure pour aller vite il faut pas
chercher à aller vite et c'est très
intéressant de en natation par exemple
l'histoire de la natation c'est très
intéressant d'un point de vue de
l'activité motrice des nageurs jeux de
rome en 1960 le vainqueur du 100 m nage
libre
en 1967 un australien il s'appelle john
des 8 et 7 australiens pour nager sont
50 mètres fait cinquante deux coups de
bras sur la longueur du bassin de 50
mètres d'accord et lui il va être
champion olympique en nage en 52
secondes et quelques dixièmes en 2008 à
pékin alain bernard qui deviendra donc
le champion olympique du 100 m nage
libre
naj 47 secondes 46 quelque chose proche
de 47 secondes et vous savez combien il
coûte bravard 50 m 28 coup de bras ça
veut dire que cette évolution absolument
incroyable du rapport d'un être humain
dans l'eau celle inverse de la volonté
d'aller vite en tournant les bras vite
mais au contraire c'est la capacité
admis à utiliser de mieux en mieux le
fluide pour devenir de plus en plus
efficaces donc à vouloir quelques fois
demandé à des enfants d'aller de plus en
plus vite et de confondre aller vite
avec tourner les bras vite c'est une
erreur absolument pédagogique qui crée
quelques fois les conditions
des chèques dont on se remet jamais donc
ça c'est très intéressant
et la deuxième chose sur laquelle je
voudrais peut-être conclure parce
qu'elle elle ouvre des perspectives
intéressantes c'est qu'en maths à sion
il ya une formule toute simple qu'on en
oublie quelquefois c'est que la
résistance à l'avancement vous piette
des universitaires la résistance à
l'avancement en natation
c'est le produit d'un certain nombre de
facteurs mais qui est dépendant du carré
de la vitesse
ça veut dire que plus vous allez aller
vite
plus vous allez augmenter la résistance
alors par rapport à ce choix
quand vous avez la responsabilité de
réfléchir stratégiquement ce que vous
allez engager en termes techniques bio
mécanique et c'est avec vous avec vos
athlètes et vos nageurs bien nous avons
fait le choix non pas de travailler sur
les conditions biomécanique d'aller vite
mais nous avons d'abord travaillé sur la
diminution des résistances diminution du
maître couple enfin et c est finalement
pendant nos adversaires faisait de la
muscu nous on travaillait sur la
diminution des résistances et donc à
vitesse égale capacité physique égale
celui qui résiste moins aux fluides va
être devant c'est des petites choses
mais à la fin quand on gagne on est
champion olympique pour trois centièmes
ou deux centièmes quelquefois ça fait ça
fait la différence et c'est une belle
métaphore cette résistance qui dépend du
carré de la vitesse
parce qu'on peut l'adapter dans tous les
aspects du management c'est à dire que à
chaque fois que vous allez vouloir
transformer quelque chose une
organisation
une équipe anne athlètes lui-même à
chaque fois que vous allez vouloir aller
vite
vous allez multiplier les conditions de
la résistance c'est une leçon
moi qui me passionne c'est à dire que
finalement plutôt que de vouloir à
priori décidé que nous allons aller vite
vers l'objectif que nous nous sommes
fixés si nous analysions ensemble ce qui
fait résistance à cette volonté là et
dès l'instant où on va être d'accord
pour ne plus résister à ce qui va se
mettre en oeuvre
très vite on va voir que les décisions
vont se prendre dans l'efficacité et la
volonté de faire ensemble
donc cette petite formule qui est une
petite formule comme ça j'utilise
beaucoup pour dire la vitesse c'est bien
mais souvent c'est quelque chose qu'on
recherche dans le sport de haut niveau
mais ça doit pas être l'outil de des
managers ça doit pas être l'outil de
ceux qui sont en capacité de décider
seul outil essentiel de ceux qui sont
capacité de décider d'accompagner ces la
culture un manager doit être cultivé
doit être cultivé non pas seulement de
son activité
il doit être cultivée par exemple je lis
beaucoup de bouquins de philo parce que
c'est souvent dans la philo j'ai trouvé
des réponses aux questions qu'ils se
posaient devant moi parce que les
questions qui se posaient à moi comme
manager d'une équipe nationale s'était
d'abord dès que des questions qui
concernait la condition humaine des gens
étaient là avec qui je travaillais et où
trouve-t-on des réponses à la condition
humaine
mais d'abord en philosophie or le sport
le sport c'est de plus en plus et c'est
ce qui m'inquiète quelque chose qui est
considéré uniquement comme du corps en
action c'est à dire que vous voyez se
développer de manière absolument
incroyable des moyens technologiques etc
pour développer le physique des athlètes
et on oublie une chose essentielle c'est
qu'un athlète c'est d'abord un être
humain qui s'est fixé un objectif et sur
lequel il va essayer de construire le
chemin
qui vont lui permettre d'accéder à ces
chemins et ça ça réclame du temps ça
réclame beaucoup de temps ces réclames
de la réflexion et ça réclame je dirais
pour conclure de l'intelligence je
remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]